je me suis demandé pourquoi ils m'ont
mis en premier alors je me suis dit
c'est pas parce que je suis plus
intéressant que les autres ça par
rapport
je me suis dit dans le fond ça prend
quelqu'un pour être jetés dans la fosse
aux lions
puis il en fait comme les romains ont
pris le chrétien et puis l'ont jeté de
belles dents qui est spirituel lui vaut
cette fibre les autres donc c'est
correct je dis ok le tanka est le
premier temps qu'a lancé le bal je me
suis dit j'ai assez de le faire de façon
canon moi j'ai l'habitude de toujours
lancer quelque chose en audience
quand je commence mes présentations la
dernière fois j'avais lancé des fleurs
je lance pas de tomates cheveux jamais
sûr pas sinon les gens reçoivent on
devrait vous lancez une question je vais
vous lancer la plus grande question que
l'humanité se pose en fait que l'être
humain se pose depuis qu'il est
conscient lui même qui suis-je
une grande question mais les courtes
seulement trouées vous mêlez très
puissante qui sommes-nous véritablement
sommes nous des êtres biologique
pourvu d'une conscience évolue et ça
c'est ce que darwin nous y l'évolution
nous amener à ça où sommes nous des
êtres conscients qu'ils vivent une
expérience des restrictions dans un
corps biologique
ces deux choses complètement différentes
les neurosciences nous disent que
l'esprit humain provient du
fonctionnement du cerveau et on a des
tonnes de preuve de ça son regard des
gens qui souffrent de maladie
d'alzheimer on le voit bien
ces gens-là perdre la perte de leur
identité ils perdent le contact avec les
autres ils s'évanouissent il dit
donc c'est vrai qu'on est le pro du
cerveau mais est ce qu'on lit totalement
et est ce qu'on lit uniquement ou est-ce
qu autre chose
moi c'est une question que je me pose
depuis bien longtemps dans ma vie et je
vais vous expliquer d'où est-ce que je
viens avec son inquiétez vous pas le jeu
je me suis pourvu au dessus de mon lit
je suis pas parti dans un tunnel
j'ai pas vu de lumière au bout puis j'ai
pris ma grand-mère m'accueillir des
bronzes luanda moxico pendant des années
je n'ai rien je suis je reçois goats
kassian depuis très longtemps depuis que
je suis tout jeune j'avais 10 ans puis
jalenques mpeg et je regardais dehors
des étoiles le ciel la nuit et je me
disais cet univers noyer fantastique qui
est incroyable et complexes d'où est ce
que ça vient et je me suis questionnée
aussi sur l'être humain en général le
génie humain comment ça se fait que cet
univers leur a amené l'espèce homo
sapiens un point autant évolué qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est capable de créer
des choses fantastiques tout ça moi je
me disais ça se peut pas que ça vienne
juste d'un organiste biologique qui doit
certainement voir autre chose en dessous
de tout nous sommes qui marque un
chaînon landes
à quelques pas alors moi je veux
d'étudier sur le point de vue des
neurosciences et si on regarde la
science typiquement l'être humain a été
pris en charge par certaines disciplines
sociable et entre autres la question de
spiritualité elle est devenue la
propriété des religions c'est normal
parce que les prophètes sont arrivés ici
et ils nous ont dit y avait autre chose
ailleurs
donc la religion c'est approprié de tout
ça il ya des gens qui ont partie des
religions puis la spiritualité c'est une
question de religion
moi je veux revenir à la science pour ce
que la spiritualité de nos jours c'est
plus qu'une question de religion je
crois c'est plus une question
personnelle une question identitaire une
question humaine
puis que maintenant que les religions se
font secouer parce qu'avec la science le
des nouvelles choses qui arrivent la
science donne des explications
la science nous permet de comprendre le
fonctionnement des choses
alors je me dis on a un peu trop qu'est
la religion pour les sciences puis la
science est devenu un petit peu notre
bible alors pourquoi ne pas partir de
l'assiette pour étudier la question de
la spiritualité intéressant comme point
de vue mais souhaite un blocage la
science ne s'intéresse pas aux choses
immatérielles la science s'intéresse aux
choses factuelles aux choses matérielles
auxquelles correct mais les
neurosciences
elle s'intéresse à l'être humain les
neurosciences s'intéressent au
fonctionnement du cerveau mais au
fonctionnement d'un être humain et au
fonctionnement de l'esprit humain
alors les neurosciences font partie de
la science mais peuvent nous aider a
expliqué l'être humain pu expliquer
peut-être la question de la spiritualité
alors c'est une piste intéressante puis
un nouveau domaine qui se développe à
l'intérieur d'une rue science qui
s'appelle les neurosciences de la
spiritualité
moi j'ai eu l'occasion de m'asseoir avec
un monsieur qui s'appelle mario
beauregard qui est un chef de file en
matière de neurosciences de spiritualité
à travers le monde et ce monsieur loeb
il reste à quai des arts à montréal
pardon au québec à montréal
je passe en après midi un culte et
fantastique moi j'ai vraiment tripé
vraiment soleil pour ne rien pris on a
juste parlé alors je vais aborder cette
question de de spiritualité à partir des
neurosciences
maintenant avant de commencer et de se
lancer dans le vide se lancer dans le
cosmos vers l'au-delà avec notre habits
de cosmonautes notes épicées
scientifique
j'aimerais qu'on définisse c'est quoi
l'expérience spirituelle
est-ce que c'est dieu est ce que ces dix
ans
qu'est ce que c'est les rois mages juste
que c'est le petit jésus parce que c'est
le mot du petit jésus on est en décembre
donc on va regarder plus en détail c'est
quoi ce pigment l'expérience spirituelle
c'est une expérience d'intériorité
mais c'est une expérience où l'individu
sans qu'ils aient beaucoup plus que sa
coquille ou l'individu vont plus loin
que ça
donc une notion de présence linda une
présence intérieure très grande immense
qui dépasse le contexte de l'individu
une notion aussi de conscience une prise
de conscience que la personne est plus
que juste le petit jeu mental qu'il
s'est créées à partir du moment qu'ils
étaient tous et jusqu'à l'âge adulte à y
aussi beaucoup d'amour
on peut pas parler de spiritualité sans
parler d'amour d'amour envers soi mais
l'amour aussi envers l'humanité ça
déborde de notre personne dans une
expérience spirituelle
la notion d'unicité ont fait un avec
tous tout est un tout est interrelié il
ya aussi beaucoup de sentiment de paix
de sérénité de joie alors c'est ça
l'expérience spirituelle et on voit la
décortiquer bon je parlais de séance
tout à l'heure la science s'intéresse
aux choses matérielles
oui c'est vrai mais est elle aussi
matériel qu'on pense
on remet en question ces choses là grâce
à la physique quantique
premièrement la tombe qu'on croyait à
être très matérielle la tombe qui est à
la base de tout ce qui est ici tout ce
qui est fait matériellement de cet
entonnoir n'est pas si matériel
compenser la tombe en fait c'est
d'énergie c'est de l'énergie empaqueté
dans une forme légale mc 2 unleashed
hines est le lien entre la matière et
l'énergie c'est la lumière
c'est drôle parce qu'un type ritualité
on parle souvent lumière aussi a fait la
tombe c'est des petites boules d'énergie
c'est comme les enfants des petites
boules d'énergie
c'est la même chose s'est mise à tomber
va aussi les constitutions de la tombe
quand on regarde les particules des
attentes on s'aperçoit ces particules en
existe pour réellement en tant que tel
physiquement elles ne sont pas définies
dans le temps et l'espace
elle occupe une probabilité d'existence
alentours du noyau donc des fois elle se
manifeste comme des particules des fois
même comme des ans on aperçoit la
dualité
donc même cette matière là dans
l'infiniment petit
on la regarde on voit qu'elle n'est
peut-être pas autant m'attire matériel
et qu'on pense il ya un monsieur ici que
vous voyez qui s'appelle nice bolt a été
l'instigateur d'un physique quantique
lui même le dit que je vais vous le
traduire tout ce qu'on croit réel effet
chose sous jacente qui ne peuvent pas
être appelé réel un autre monsieur que
j'aime bien parce que c'est un ingénieur
il ya une très belle coupe de cheveux
d'ailleurs lui avait promis des
problèmes d'électricité statique dans sa
maison cet ingénieur électrique
nikola tesla on lui doit une grosse
partie de notre société aujourd'hui lui
même disait que l'univers pour le
comprendre faut penser en termes de
vibrations en terme de fréquence en
terme de situation à moi en tant
qu'ingénieur fit signer je me fie à ce
que les plus grands ingénieurs les plus
grands fils et on dit puis je crois
personnellement que l'univers est
beaucoup plus serré qu'on pense changer
vos lunettes et il se manifestera
différemment maintenant au niveau des
neurosciences on voit aussi que le
matérialisme est en train de disparaître
oui c'est vrai qu'on y produit du
cerveau mais il ya des expériences qui
nous démontre que l'esprit peut
influencer de ça on appelle cela la
neuroplasticité l'autre jour j'en parle
à ma petite fille faisait à papa on voit
surtout de la platine pour vous faire
des cerveaux j'ai dit et le dit tout
compris c'est exactement sur la
neuroplasticité c'est la possibilité de
prendre notre esprit puis de façonner
notre cerveau à personne entre esprit et
ça c'est très concret c'est très l'effet
placebo le démontre on fait des
recherches avec des antidépresseurs et
tout ça des gens qui prennent un placebo
vers son antidépresseur ont des effets
sur leurs cerveaux chimique est une
neuro neurologiques mureaux systémique
la même chose au niveau de la méditation
ceux qui font beaucoup de méditation on
voit des changements importants dans le
cerveau niveau de la structure du
cerveau et ceux qui font des thérapies
cognitives c'est la même chose
tous ces gens là à travers d'études ont
été portés dans des scans et on a vu que
leurs murs aux structures et des têtes
ce faire donc l'esprit peut influencer
le cerveau mais ce qu'on peut dire que
l'esprit peut vivre en dehors du cerveau
parce que c'est une autre affaire c'est
comme un pc qu'un logiciel
le logiciel a besoin du pc pour
fonctionner les deux fonctionnent en
synergie
est ce que l'esprit peut fonctionner en
dehors du cerveau bien ça prend cette
synergie doigts pour fonctionner sur
grande question se pose question qui
serait pas facilement non plus on va
regarder ce que la médecine dite de son
les expériences de mort provisoire là je
parle pas de mort imminente je parle de
mort provisoire des gens qui sont morts
pour de vrai cliniquement le cabaret de
battre le cerveau et flatline sur le
plan cérébral et plus rien puis ces gens
là sont réanimés par la suite on a un
certain nombre de minutes pour
déterminer un vainqueur et un brio au
niveau de la structure cellulaire
il ya aussi des opérations qui appelle
cardiaque stand still ils prennent les
gens ils font un arrêt cardiaque
ils plongent leur température corporelle
à 60 degrés ils font l'opération il
réanime deux heures après c'est les gens
là ils reviennent avec des histoires
puis là je parle pas de l'histoire comme
disons via un tunnel ils ont vu une
lumière ils ont vu à grand-mère ou
bottes je parle pas de ça je parle de
gens qui ont décrit des choses très
factuelle des choses alentours de la
salle d'opération le médecin et audi
telle chose
l'infirmière brutale instruments et on
fait telle chose sur moi comme impliqués
sont alors que la personne était
complètement arrêté sous le principe sur
le plan cérébral
ceci c'est assez déroutant puis
présentement il ya des études qui seront
très sérieuse pour essayer de comprendre
ce phénomène qui voit aussi a pas
quelque chose de suggestions donc
aujourd'hui j'ai pas de réponse
définitive à vous donner
je peux pas vous dire que oui ou non on
n'est que le produit de notre cerveau
par contre on a des pistes intéressantes
il ya des éléments qui tendent à me
démontrer que possiblement plus mais on
attend des preuves scientifiques et je
crois personnellement poursuivre les
neurosciences depuis dix ans que les
prochaines années ils ont les prochaines
vingt à vingt années vont réveiller
beaucoup de choses intéressantes sur la
conscience humaine en lien avec le
fonctionnement cérébral mais pose sur la
conscience humaine en général où la
conscience de l'être la conscience de
l'esprit pour terminer
j'aimerais vous alliez sur une piste de
réflexion si on pouvait obtenir une
réponse définitive une véritable réponse
scientifique sans l'ombre d'un doute
parce qu'on a tous un doute on ne sait
pas à 100% si on va passer le cap
diamant
il y en a qui disent que oui mais qui
c'est qui peut le dire donc 100% certain
pile prouver la personne peut faire ça
encore
si on trouve une réponse dans les six
prochaines années là dessus
la réponse est lié we will i nom commun
vous envisageriez votre vie
suite à cette réponse qu'est ce que ça
changerait d'entre eux vit dans votre
vie complètement
qu'est ce que vous feriez de différent
si la réponse est oui
est ce que vous dites parce que nous ne
savons pas bien de secret ici on va
développer encore plus de fun ou si la
réponse est non mais pourquoi on se fait
que receipt façon rien après fait ça
dépend comment nous avons pu voir
complètement l'inversé
mais qu'est ce qui changera aussi sur le
point sur le point de vue social qu'est
ce qui se passerait dans la société
comment les gens réagir et est ce qu est
ce qu on verrait comme changement de
structure sociale ou dans nos
interactions avec les autres et quels
changements ont viré on verra au niveau
de notre évolution en tant qu'humain
quelle nouvelle direction peut-être on
pourrait prendre
alors c'est tout des questions très
intéressantes à se poser et j'aimerais
bien les analyser avec vous ces
questions là une par une à la peau vous
vous sincèrement faire énormément
plaisir
je conclus lettres suffit je vous
remercie beaucoup de votre attention